laquelle vous tente le plus jeune avait
que la nature les jeunes c'est plutôt ce
quand même celle ci donne plus de 5 m
je prendrai le duo pourquoi parce que je
suis bien d'accord c'est que des
babioles pour boire contre eux c'est
devant que tu es la médaille d'or au
viol qu'est ce qui nous fait choisir
d'un plutôt qu'un autre
c'est ce qu'on cherche à savoir à
l'école de commerce de dijon un
chercheur grec s'est installé dans un
bâtiment dédié avec un professeur il
étudie depuis plusieurs mois le
comportement des acheteurs novembre
notamment l'influencé des labels sur
l'achat de qualité pour eux alors que
les connaisseurs eux ont vraiment d idée
plus précise de ce qu'ils veulent et ils
n'ont pas besoin de ces signaux là
puisqu'ils connaissent la qualité des
vins à travers d'autres signaux qui sont
que subtile pour les consommateurs
inexpérimentés ils sont attirés par la
beauté du label où ils connaissent le
nom ou parfois même le domaine mais
l'esthétique compte beaucoup
viré clessé est très très bien je sais
pas si vous connaissez
à partir de là par contre sur un blanc
selon ce qu'a bistre les prix et la
belle influence seulement les
consommateurs lorsqu'ils achètent dans
la grande distribution sont les clients
qui rentre chez moi viennent chercher un
conseil ils sont pas forcément à la
recherche de la médaille ou du petit
macaron qui est là pour les rassurer
puisque normalement c'est moi qui suis
là pour les rassurer
il faudra encore des années pour que le
laboratoire publie sa première étude
pour déceler le choix des français en
matière de l'an
et le support majeur